right
welcome to lectures uh seven and eight
um
we're gonna talk about risk preferences
hello we're gonna talk about
risk preferences in particular sort of
from the perspective of expected utility
which is sort of the classical way of
economics to view this
um this is gonna take like one and a
half perhaps two lectures
um broadly speaking we're going to look
at sort of like what does economics
usually assume how does economics think
about risk preferences
about choices involving risk
how do we think about sort of measuring
risk preferences
um what are some of the implications and
what are the some of the limits of risk
preferences in terms of like what we can
explain
and what we can not explain and then uh
in the following lectures then we're
going to have like an alternative model
of reference dependence preferences
where essentially
we're going to relax or change some of
the underlying assumptions on how to
measure preferences related to risk
problem set two will be posted uh uh
soon later this week i i'm sure you
uh can't wait for this a reminder um uh
late submissions will not be accepted uh
i uh this is always like a commitment
problem because people come up with all
sorts of
good excuses why um uh they submitted
the problem said late and then i kind of
feel bad about it
so i'm here with uh committing to not
accepting any late submissions for
whatever reasons unless you have sort of
a medical uh
excuse or like uh uh sort of an excused
sq uh notice so no my pdf was corrupted
and all sorts of other good reasons
as a student once as well and i know
students are very um creative
um we will post previous problem sets
midterms in finals for you to practice
overall i think of the problem sets less
of a way for
testing you or testing sort of uh
whether you can do it or not but rather
as a way for you to practice things
whether you have understood
uh the materials so like in parts of the
past problem sets and
midterms and finals supposed to help you
with that as usual please
ask questions on piazza or come to
office hours
so what we're going to talk about is
broadly speaking risk aversion how do
economists
think about choices involving risk
then again i sort of outline um sort of
the very simple or the basic model of
uh the main workhorse model of economics
to think about choices involving risk
which is the expected utility
model we're going to then think about
kind of like how do we measure risk
preferences the underlying preference
parameters
that sort of are embedded in this model
we're going to lead them
to like some absurd implications in
particular sort of discrepancy how
people
tend to think about small scale and
large-scale risk aversion what i mean by
that but essentially small gambles that
involve a few dollars versus like
really large-scale choices that involve
like thousands of dollars
and what i'm going to show you kind of
very similar to some degree
uh to how we think about time
preferences where um
the typical exponential discounting
model
cannot explain both a short run and long
run
time preference decision that people
make that's just sort of calibrationally
very hard to do
similarly the expected utility model has
problems with like
reconciling small scale and large-scale
choices that people make
i'll tell you that in more detail but in
short the summary is if people
are risk-averse when it comes to small
gambles
that implies that like they're absurdly
risk-averse coming from large gamble if
you sort of take that model seriously
and so that's kind of like not not
really true in reality
and so then we sort of think about kind
of how to relax on those kinds of
assumptions
okay so first let's think about kind of
like what kinds of choices and decisions
do in fact
involve risk and uncertainty what
examples do we have
in your life what is risky or what what
involves uncertainty
yes
[Music]
right whether you're not whether it's
you not to get education whether or not
to study and so on
because the reward often is like
uncertain right you might get a job you
might not get a job you might do really
well in college you might not
uh and so on and so forth so like the
costs
and the costs you might like it you
might not like it and so on it's not
clear
so the costs and benefits are uncertain
there might be a recession when you
graduate and so on and so forth so like
the returns and
costs are both uncertain
yes
yeah exactly you buy you you might buy a
house um
uh or you might think about like buying
or renting uh more broadly
um and there it depends a lot on
essentially what's happening to the
housing market if the housing market
goes up or down
uh the choice to buy a house versus
renting is very
different right so if the housing market
goes up most likely you should probably
buy a house
the housing market actually happens the
tank the next post at least it's a bad
idea
to do so yes
right so the two choices that we had so
far were essentially choices involving
risk where you sort of essentially
decide to do something where the
outcomes
are uncertain or risky in some way now
what you're saying in some sense is like
a bunch of other choices potentially are
risk mitigation strategies right
so you have essentially certain risks in
your life and you have choices where you
could say i could buy insurance so i
could sort of
make other choices that mitigate or
reduce the risk that i'm
exposed to and one sort of canonical
example of that is
purchasing any type of insurance but in
particular sort of renters
insurance as you mentioned yes yeah
they choose to grow yes so like
essentially
i call that sort of like and develop in
particular or development economics
in particular there's lots of issues of
production choices that people
make um this could be like what crops to
grow whether you should buy a machine
uh whether you should start a business
and so on so it's all sorts of like
choices
in terms of what business to go into um
what kinds of um
specifics uh what products to sell if
you have a business
and then the farmer case like you know
what crops should you uh
grow should you buy fertilizer should
you use other inputs and so on and so
forth
uh should you do we d like there's a
bunch of different other so you inter
crop like there's a bunch of different
other um
uh choices that you could make that
essentially involve
um risk because the outcome essentially
is uncertain
because essentially you know the season
might be good or bad in the farmer's
case
if you for example purchase fertilizer
or certain uh for example you could
purchase or use drought resistant crops
of course if there's no drought then
that's not really that helpful but if
there's a drought
that's really high return to to to do
yes yes
creating uh yeah so uh
investing your money into a different in
the stock market or um
in in other sort of in bonds or the like
uh you know what how
how should you invest that money that's
kind of like related to some uh so some
degree um
to the um renting versus buying house
you can think of like buying as a house
uh as like one asset one potential very
sort of a liquid asset that you could
buy
similarly you could you could buy stocks
you could pay bonds you could like keep
just cash
and so on and there that very much
depends on the return depends on
uh things that are out of your hand
which essentially is just what what the
stock market
might do so i think once you think about
sort of like um
choices involving um risk um essentially
almost any choice in in your life
actually
um is risky to some degree or uncertain
uh ranging from like going to college
doing problem sets
uh studying for exams which exam should
you study for which questions
are people can ask health decisions
should you
should you invest in your health or not
for a lot of diseases that people might
get
uh it's often very uncertain right so
even if you're like smoking a lot
not every smoker um falls sick or
like you know that just the the risk of
cancer and other diseases increases
um there's sort of financial incent and
investments
uh uh dating choices and so on and so
forth um even friendship choices are
sometimes
risky if you want riding your bicycle
there's very sort of um
small choices wearing a helmet versus
not essentially almost anything in your
life if you think about sort of what are
the outcomes what are the different
choices that you have
and what are the outcomes associated
with those choices
almost all of those choices are
associated with
uncertainty in a sense like you're not
quite sure as the return you want to be
high or low
then as i said before in addition to
that there's sort of mis
risk mitigating strategies in the sense
of like you have a lot of choices a lot
of issues that are associated with risk
and now you can choose to reduce your
exposure to risk by purchasing insurance
or for example also by avoiding certain
um uh
behaviors right so if you're if you're
worried about sort of being robbed for
example in a certain
part of town you might sort of choose to
go through that part of town
and that's a risky thing to do or you
can have sort of like risk mitigating
strategies where you just don't leave
your house or just go in different ways
or just never go into certain areas
which essentially are ways to to protect
you to reduce your risk exposure
um overall any questions
[Applause]
okay so now let me sort of just still
tell you like three broad stylized facts
that we're gonna try and explain or try
and sort of
to tackle and that's kind of what
economics is trying to do
so the first question is the first thing
that comes to mind when you think about
economics
and modeling choices involving risk is
risk aversion
how do we think about risk aversion what
is risk aversion
why are people averse to risk yeah
risk aversion is a tendency to avoid
vets that are more risky
even though they will still stand up
so one you say essentially if there are
certain bets that involve
risk where like say the expected value
so an expectation
you're going to do pretty well perhaps
better than like some safe outcomes
people tend to avoid those kinds of
threats
and that we might call risk aversion
right so that's exactly right
um but now why are people doing that
like what are the underlying reasons for
that
yes um potentially involved
is loss aversion which um
you know in in the readings i believe uh
uh some studies by uh and others were
mentioned
that showed that we had aversion
specifically to
using uh money or utility rather than
like
risk in and of itself
right so one part would be to say people
might sort of lose or
gain money in certain gambles and
what you're saying is essentially people
might not treat the losses the same as
they treat the
gains and then you might sort of decline
certain
gambles or certain risks you might you
just worried about losing
uh out and you put a lot of value on
that that's exactly right we're going to
talk about this um
uh next week in a lot more detail um
what what are some other reasons why
people might not want to to to engage in
risk
yes
and why is that
right so one part is and that's exactly
how economists think about this is
diminishing marginal utility that's to
say
getting a first dollar if you're really
poor getting your first dollar has
really high value to you
the reason being that like now
essentially otherwise you would starve
or you can't eat and so on you can you
know the value of whatever you
purchase with that dollar is really high
because you just have nothing otherwise
now if i give you a million dollars and
then another dollar then essentially the
additional dollar that i give you after
the million is just not doing very much
so the marginal utility of that dollar
is low in that sort of diminishing
marginal utility of
wealth that's exactly how economists
talk about this we're going to get back
to that in a lot of detail
[Music]
right so there might be sort of certain
minimum standards in some sense that
people have
over their uh outcomes where you say for
example
you really want to have like a place to
sleep or want to have some meal
and essentially if you're below that
threshold essentially you
your marginal utility anywhere below
that uh
is really high because you really want
to get over that threshold and
so you might sort of like avoid certain
uh
choices or investments or the like
if there's even a small chance of like
getting below your threshold
you might be really averse to that but
what are sort of some more perhaps
psychological reasons why people don't
like
um risks yeah
but so that's right that's what people
do we're gonna also talk about that
but like why do people not like the risk
or
something some people like actually risk
but what is the issue about like
having a lot of exposure like why do
people purchase insurance for example
yes there's some amount
[Music]
right so there's one part is what you
said which is like there's diminishing
marginal utility of wealth and this is
exactly how we're going to model this
and how economists think about this
however there's other things involved
which is just things like anxiety or
uncertainty people might just not
uh suppose a storm is coming up i might
purchase insurance and if i purchase
insurance
like flood insurance of the lake for for
a house
i might just feel much i might sleep
better at nights and so on and so forth
i might just be
feel better about sort of like uh
concerns or like health insurance for
example might
uh lower anxiety and so on because
people are just not worried constantly
about like falling ill
or like disasters happening and that's
beyond potentially
uh any diminishing uh marginal utility
of wealth
that sort of anxiety is stress worries
um and so on
any other reasons yeah
i think even beyond people wanting to
like not be stressed and anxious there's
also the element of
if you're buying insurance to like
smooth your consumption between
like different states of the world it
makes it a lot easier to plan for states
after
yes that's exactly right so so in some
sense if you have insurance if you
reduce
risks in the states of the world you can
sort of essentially exclude a bunch of
bad states of the world for example
suppose you buy health insurance or both
you have flood insurance and so on
a lot of bad things that might happen
you might be able to deal with and you
don't have to necessarily
have a contingent plan of like what if i
fall sick and then go bankrupt then like
all sorts of other bad things happen
or you know what if i there's flood
insurance i can't pay the bills and then
have to
leave my house and so on so essentially
it makes planning easier
in part because it's just sort of easier
in the mind people feel more comfortable
and part it's
actually computational or just easier um
to do
so i um added some reasons here there's
a bunch of different reasons i think
it's important to understand that
economists have modeled a
risk aversion as diminishing marginal
utility of wealth that's a very simple
way of doing this
it captures a lot of things but perhaps
not all of them
and so um uh here's some reasons that i
mentioned sort of contingent planning uh
becomes harder if you have risks that's
what maya just said
um people are worried or stressed or are
you know
um anxious when they have lots of
uncertainty
um people might feel regret over missed
opportunity that's like
if i offer you some insurance right now
um and you might say well you know
um it's actually unlikely that that
anything bad happens
but in case something really bad happens
and you had the chance to actually avoid
it
then you might feel particularly bad not
just because the outcome is bad
but but because i offered it to you and
you didn't accept it
there's sort of like disappointment
relative to expectations this is
essentially
getting into territory of losses and
gains when people have certain
expectations to have an expectation to
have a certain income and the like
now if like bad stuff happens they fall
below those expectations and perceive
those outcomes than as losses compared
to
the status quo or the expectations that
they had again
economists think about this as
diminishing marginal utility of wealth
that's a very simple way of modeling
this um
and we're going to see kind of like what
the limitations of those are
now i'm going to show you three stylized
facts about
the world and then we're going to
discuss kind of like how to perhaps
model that so the first one is
essentially very simple
people are risk-averse in various
ways and one sort of basic fact is that
lots of people buy insurance people are
willing to pay to purchase insurance
that gives you
essentially money or an expectation less
money than you pay
right so fair insurance as economists
would model it or think about it is to
say
if i purchase insurance that pays you
the expected value of the insurance
so if i pay a premium for an insurance
there's a probability of something bad
happening and then sort of like a loss
that i
or some insurance payment that i get in
case something bad happens
fair insurance would be like the premium
is essentially an expectation the same
as
uh uh the probability of or is the same
as the expectation of
the loss which is the probability of the
loss occurring and the actual payment
that i get from the insurance
of course the insurance industry wants
to make money so the insurance industry
will uh
will not offer fair insurance but like
less than fair insurance like
essentially
uh there's a price for purchasing
insurance lots of people are willing to
pay for insurance people are willing to
pay
money to get insurance to reduce the
risk or the exposure to risks that they
have
their social security and various ways
where essentially
people sort of insure themselves or like
society ensures them
for old age or not being able to take
care of themselves you could argue
that's perhaps also due to like present
bias so other
paternalistic reasons but surely like
society in some senses helping people
insure themselves against potential
states of the world um where there might
be a need
there's very sort of other institut
sorry
institutions including sort of extended
families and formal insurance in
developing countries
sharecropping and so on and so forth
what's sharecropping
yes
no that's inter cropping or like
but that might be referred to that as
well yeah it's like
when when the person runs out their land
you get kind of all the benefits from
the land
but they take the ramp
right exactly so it's essentially these
kinds of arrangement um uh which often
somebody has land
uh uh somebody rents out the land and
then um
uh you have to pay them something back
uh and then
can keep some of the output and so on
and often that's essentially some way of
like essentially
reducing risk so there's various sort of
institutions but broadly speaking we
think like in many situations people
don't like risk and they look for ways
to reduce the exposure
to risks there's also like these
informal insurance arrangements
which are things like you know people uh
get together and they sort of help each
other whenever something bad happens uh
one person
um uh uh is then being helped by
everybody else
uh and sort of uh that sort of replacing
some sort of formula
for insurance schemes in particular in
developing countries
second risk reduction has its price that
is to say
people are willing to take on risk if
the return is high enough so another way
to put this is like if you want to
purchase insurance
usually you have to pay for it like the
insurance industry makes a lot of money
for differently like um
people are willing to take on some risk
if things get cheaper right for example
you think about buying a car
you could buy a super safe car with all
sorts of safety features not everybody
does that the reason is
because you know cheaper cars or or less
safe cars are
cheaper so you might just sort of
willing to take on some risk in some
situations
for some price right when you think
about like starting a restaurant
restaurants essentially um fail all the
time yet people are sort of willing to
do it presumably the reason is because
if you
actually succeed you're going to make
quite a bit of money
so if there's like a high expected
return people are willing to take on um
some risks
people put in money into the stock
market so they increase their risk
exposure
the reason why they do that is because
in expectation they make quite a bit of
money
um um but of course that often entails
risk so one way to think about the
entire sort of finance industry is like
risk intermediation essentially there's
some businesses that have a lot of risk
and that risk is sort of off-loaded to
investors and the investors accept that
risk they say i'm willing to take on
that risk
but only um for a good return right so
i'm not going to like take on risk from
you
if i'm not in expectation making money
but often essentially there's a
trade-off between and this is whole if
you're taking finance classes and so on
that's kind of obvious
there's a trade-off between risk and
expected return
okay in what situations are people
actually willing to take on risk
for its own sake or just
so i told you like people are risk
averse and that's true in most
situations
but where are people actually willing to
take on risks yes
right lots of people actually go to
casinos and here
the expected um return is actually um a
negative or the expected you know like
you're going to lose money on average
unless you're sort of like
a smart mit students who can count cards
in poker or something
you're going to lose money essentially
so there must be some form of like some
preference or some desire to take on
risk in some situations
because you know you cannot just this is
not like investing in the stock market
where on average you're going to
get money if you go to the casino on
average you're going to lose money
now you could say it's like so much fun
and so on it could also be addiction it
could be also self-control issues and so
on
or there could be something about
people's beliefs or preferences that
induce them to take on risk
but notice that's different from what we
discussed before that's not really
consistent with like
risk aversion because people choose to
increase the risk that they're exposed
to
any other um yeah
exactly people are buying lots of
lottery tickets uh similar they're doing
lots of sports betting
and again what you're doing here is like
to be very clear on average you're going
to lose money
that you're going to increase risk or
the exposure to risk
and there's some questions on why people
are doing this we're going to get back
to this we're going to knock not to talk
about this today but it's sort of on a
flag that
while people are risk averse in many and
almost uh nearly all situations
of the world are important choices that
you encounter there are some choices
where people are in fact
um exposing themselves to to to to risk
in addition to
exposure to risk that actually has high
expected value
any questions on this
okay so now we're going to talk about
the expected utility um and sort of how
do economists think about um
uh uh uh how should we behave and that's
a normative model
how do economists think about like how
people should behave when it comes to
choices involving risk so what is um
what is expected utility
what does the model assume or what is it
about
right exactly so um the assumption here
is there's different states of the world
there's good things and bad things may
happen you might
get a job you might not get a job you
might get a good grade bad grade and so
on
you can sort of like partition the world
or anything that's going to happen in
the future into different states of the
world
we can associate a utility
uh as an outcome and an associated
utility with that state of the world
right if you get a good job you get a
high income again
if you don't get a job get a low income
or whatever or unemployment insurance or
whatever
and there are certain utilities
associated with these outcomes
expected utility now is essentially say
okay now for each of these states of the
world there's a probability of the state
of the world happening
and i'm going to use essentially the
weighted average which essentially is
weighting each state with their
associated probability
times the uh and then using the
associated utilities for each state
and the expectations of those utilities
is what's expected
utility and that's very complicated i'm
going to sort of get better let's
set in more words than the necessary let
me sort of get back to this
so first uh let's think about like
expected monetary value
so um suppose there's a gamble and this
is not very simplified there's a gamble
called g over two states of the world
state one occurs with probability p
and yields monetary payoff x state 2
occurs with probability 1 minus p and
yields monetary payoff
y now the expected monetary value now
this is not expected utility is this
expected monetary value this is how much
money you get in expectation is
essentially just the weighted average of
those two things sort of weighted by
the probabilities let's just p times x
plus 1 minus p
times y that's just the expected value
of how much money you're going to get
from this
gamble now this is just a definition a
fair
gamble and this is what economists tend
to use a lot a fair gamble is one with
um a price equal to expected to its
expected monetary value
right so if i ask you um would you like
to take this gamble
um uh you're gonna ask kind of like is
this a fair gamble
essentially that's just asking about is
it paying uh the expected value of this
uh in terms of money i put monetary in
in um
in parentheses because i could also
provide you like a fair gamble of like
apples and then it would just be the
expected value of apples
that would be also like a fair gamble
potentially
now what's the expected utility of this
gamble well now you need to have a
utility function for each of these
outcomes
so if my utility function is u of x this
is kind of like how much
utility i get for um in the state of
actually getting
x or y so called x i is like the or i
is like the state of the world so
essentially now it's the weighted
average of p
i times u of x i so in this case like p
times u of x plus y minus p times u of
y any questions on this so far
and so when you now think about
evaluating gambles using expected
utility
if your utility function is linear
then you're going to essentially decide
the same way as
if you were just evaluating the expected
monetary value right
um and if not if the utility function is
concave or convex then essentially
people are potentially
risk-averse so
how economists think about expected
monetary value is like the history of
that used to be the first theories that
people wrote down was
this was like a model how people thought
people should behave that was a
normative model that people wrote at
some point and said
you should um rational people should
should essentially maximize monetary
payouts and just to say
um uh if the expected monetary value of
a certain gamble is high you should
expect it or if it's higher than
its price then you should accept it
otherwise not now it turns out that
in practice that's not descriptively
accurate that's just not how people
behave on the world
and in fact and the reason being that
people are risk averse in most
situations
now when using now the expected monetary
value essentially we use the expected
money value as as a definition for risk
neutrality
if somebody is risk neutral if somebody
doesn't care at all about risk in some
situation
that person essentially just is
maximizing the expected monetary value
right so the decision makers and this
definition is risk neutral if for any
lottery g
she's indifferent between g and getting
the expected monetary value g
um for sure and so decision maker is
neutral if the utility function is
linear okay essentially the more money
you get then there's no diminishing
margin utility of of
money now
what's risk aversion then a decision
maker is risk averse
for any lottery g trooper prefers
getting the expected money
monetary value g for for sure rather
than taking
um g and the person is risk loving if
the person
rather has the lottery than the expected
monetary value
um for sure right these are just
definition that's just the way how
economists think about risk this
definition defining how we think about
risk aversion and risk
lovingness if you want now let me give
you just a very simple example
uh suppose a person with wealth ten
thousand dollars offered a gamble
uh the gamble is you can gain five
hundred dollars with a fifty percent
chance and lose four hundred dollars
with a fifty percent chance will you
accept this gamble
how do we do this now
suppose i'm just unexpected i'm just
maximizing the expected monetary value
what am i what am i
going to do yeah
right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to just look at what's the
expected my expected monetary value of
accepting the lottery which is 0.5 which
is like the probability of that uh
uh of a loss times nine thousand nine
thousand six hundred this is like ten
thousand minus the four hundred dilutes
plus point five times ten thousand plus
five hundred which gives me
uh ten thousand fifty if i reject the
lottery i'm just where i am before
now uh the risk neutral decision maker
will reject the gamble
in fact irrespective irrespective of the
initial wealth because essentially
everything is linear so you can just
drop out the wealth you can just look at
what's the expected value regardless of
how much money the person
has uh
yes sorry that's a typo
yes sorry that's a typo yes thank you
sorry that's
yeah so the exactly the expected
monetary value is higher than the status
quo as you
accept the gamble and that doesn't
depend on the initial wealth
okay so now what's the expected utility
maximizer do and
how does it expect it to slowly maximize
think about this
[Music]
yes um in their calculation rather than
waiting
like the 9600 and the 10
500 they'll weight the utility values
exactly so now we need the utility
function
what's the utility of 9600 the utility
of 10
500 uh and the utility of 10 000. now
will she ex
uh uh will she accepts the gamble well
now it depends essentially on
uh the utility function what's the shape
of that utility function uh look like in
particular it depends on the concavity
of the utility function
so what do i mean by um the concavity of
the utility function this is a concave
function
what do i mean by that
like what's the definition yes
right so one definition is the second
derivative is negative that's exactly
right
that's true if the the the function is
like twice differentiable you have like
a slightly different definition that's
slightly more general because it doesn't
depend on differentiability but
essentially is to say um
it's the following definition if the
utility of a convex combination of two
outcomes i'm going to tell you about
this in a second
is larger than the convex combination of
the utility of those outcomes what do i
mean by that suppose you have an outcome
x and a utility associated with that as
u of x
suppose you have an outcome y and a
utility of
u of y associated with that and now
suppose you have a convex combination of
x and y
which is just the probability of p is
like a probability of
p times x plus 1 minus p times y that's
in the middle of x and y
right so i take like a weighted average
of x and y that adds up to 1.
now if i have the utility associated
with that
convex combination that's u of p x plus
1 minus p
times y right that's just the utility
associated with that
now if i draw a line between those two
graphs and look at what's the convex
combination of p
so what's p of u of x plus 1 minus p of
u of y
that's essentially the weighted average
of the utilities associated with x and y
now the question is like is the average
of the utility of the average higher or
lower than the average of the utilities
can somebody explain this in words or
what i just said or what what do i mean
can somebody repeat this
right is the line above or below the
curve in this case the line is below the
curve
now what that means is if i give you two
outcomes and i say would you rather have
you could have x and y or would you
rather have the average to some weighted
average of x and y
now the question is what's the utility
associated
with this average of x and y that's the
thing that you see here on the left
upper side that's u of p
of x plus y minus p of y times y right
that's essentially the utility of the
weighted average
is that larger or smaller than the
weighted average of the utilities which
is the thing that i show you here below
and what you see is in this case and
this is because the line is exactly as
you say it's below the utility function
if the line is below the utility
function
that means essentially that the utility
of the weighted average
is higher than the weighted average of
the utilities
which means essentially the function is
concave
and that means essentially that the
person is risk averse as we call it
you'd rather have the average than the
spread of the two
two outcomes any questions on this or
comments
okay so you can look at this in detail
but essentially it's like a simple
um definition
so now um expected utility says
essentially the following it says a
risk-averse person rejects
all fair gambles and again fair gambles
are gambles that pay you the expected
monetary value
and the reason why that person does that
is because the expected utility
is lower than the utility of the
expected monetary value
this is exactly this essentially as you
just said
it's because the the straight line is
between below the utility function
and that's essentially exactly the same
definition here therefore
um a risk-averse person who has a
concave utility function
uh rejects all fair gumballs now
what does expected utility theory then
say well it says risky options are
valued by
by doing three things one is you have to
define utility over
final outcomes and this is sort of
getting back what you were saying
earlier
people might be worried about losses or
gains and the like
we're assuming all of this away we're
just saying like their final outcomes
how much money you have what grades you
have how many kids you have and so on
these are final outcomes
uh like things that um uh sort of for
an absolute value is defined there's a
utility associated with those outcomes
it's not about like you expected more
money or less money or the like
that's completely irrelevant we're just
looking at final outcomes how much money
do you end up actually getting
and we're associating some utility with
that that's assumption number one or
like that's the first thing one does
um second is you weight these utilities
for each outcomes by its probability
we essentially we know what the
probabilities are of each of those
outcomes
we're gonna like take the weighted
average of these utilities
and then we sort of adding them up
and then by adding them up we can
essentially we can evaluate
all sorts of lotteries and then we just
compare those lotteries with other
either with some fixed amount of money
or some other
lotteries or outcomes that we might get
now
there's two key implicit assumptions
that are really important one is only
final outcomes matter
it doesn't matter what you expected in
advance it doesn't matter what you
thought you might get and
didn't doesn't matter what you had
yesterday all of these things are
completely irrelevant in the simplest
form of expected utility
unless they sort of have information or
the like only final outcomes matter
and then there's linearity and
probabilities that's to say is like we
put
weight on the different types of states
of the world uh
relative to what the probability of
those diet states are
so it cannot be that like if something
is twice as likely you should
put twice as much weight on that and
your evaluation of the outcomes
it cannot be that like this is
non-linear in certain ways
there's linearity and probabilities
any questions on this
so now let me get back to what i said
previously what are we
assuming away here what are things that
are not in here
ugh
exactly so i'm assuming everything
essentially all the other things that we
said previously
we are assuming away for example things
like anxiety over certain outcomes
worries stress and so on i'm also
assuming the way regret
um i'm assuming away a lot of gains and
losses essentially anything we said
before is essentially just so stripped
away and simplified in some sense and
saying like
we can explain a lot of behaviors just
using the concavity of the utility
function now i have like one example for
you when i think i encourage you sort of
for any of these kinds of assumptions or
kind of
functions or things that you see in
economics it's worth sort of looking out
in the world what people are actually
doing
and uh trying to see you know is that
actually compatible with people with
behavior that we see in the world and
here's sort of one example
right so actually don't think this is a
rational behavior in the sense of like
and that's actually a good example of
like so
what we might confuse with the rational
behaviors
so i guess what we see is that
expected utility has very a lot of
trouble explaining this behavior right
because essentially you spent like five
dollars on those lotteries i'm offering
you ten dollars
so you could get twice as many tickets
so your probability of winning will be
twice as high presumably you prefer
winning over losing
so therefore you know you should
obviously take that deal unless there's
some transaction costs to the like
people are not doing that um the main
reason that's mentioned here is like
regret
now um what the person was saying like
here is like these are perhaps
irrational decisions
i actually don't think that's right
essentially it's just like we cannot
rationalize the decision that we see
with expected utility
in the sense that like it looks like the
person behaves in irrational ways
but the person may just have like regret
aversion something that essentially is
not in the utility function we sort of
modeled it in the wrong way
and sort of by not capturing this we
might miss certain behaviors
now we're going to talk a lot about not
about lotteries right now we're going to
get back to this a little bit in terms
of like
why people engage in risk but i just
want to be clear on like what we're
assuming here we're assuming a lot of
stuff away and i want you to be
aware of that um there's another
question on like which the
actually the the question of the video
did not sort of um
uh try to tackle which is like why are
people playing these lotteries in the
first place
like why engage in the lotteries in the
first place in some sense
uh that wasn't clear either again we're
going to get back to that but the the
point of the video was to
to show you the assumptions these are a
bunch of assumptions that are in the
expected utility model
not all of these assumptions are right
and you know um we want to be sort of uh
aware of that but let me sort of just
summarize what i just told you in this
and sometimes it's like recap of like uh
1401 um if you want which i think in
part you also discussed in
uh recitation or there's like a handout
from 1401 that you can sort of look at
to study it in more details so many
important economic choices involve risk
and uh people are risk averse in many um
contacts the expected utility model
is a workhorse model of economics who
are studying risk
um and the way it's sun is essentially
one takes the weighted average of
utilities from final outcomes that's
what matters for assessing
outcomes okay and so now we're gonna see
okay now
taking that model very seriously what
can be explained and what are perhaps
the limits of
of doing so now and so the risk aversion
comes
solely and exclusively from the
concavity of the utility function
there's no other reasons to avoid risk
then essentially your utility function
is concave
okay so now how do we measure risk and
that's again like sort of like
definitions that economists use
when you think about risk aversion how
do you measure this well you measure it
essentially through the concavity
of the utility function which is as you
were saying earlier it's coming from the
second derivative of the utility
function
there's two main measures that
economists use they're sort of the
absolute or the coefficient of absolute
risk aversion we call that r it's
essentially taking the
uh second derivative um which tends to
be negative so we take the negative of
that
um we scale it by the first derivative
that's essentially
to make it uh insensitive to like if you
multiply the utility function by like a
constant
presumably that doesn't change anything
to your choices so your risk aversion
should not change
um and therefore you know um uh we sort
of have to
to normalize or divide by the first
derivative
a second version of that is or an
alternative version is the
coefficient of a relative risk aversion
which essentially is
we call it gamma gamma is x
the outcome of the wealth outcome that
we look at times
r times the coefficient of absolute risk
aversion
it's the elasticity of the slope of the
utility function
which i've written out here and sort of
one very nice property of this and again
that's like a definition there's not
much to argue with this sister saw
economists measure this
one nice property of this is like if you
look at uh portfolio models so the like
when implications of um constant
relative risk aversion which i'm going
to show you a function of in a bit
is that people with constant relative
risk aversion invest a constant share of
their wealth and risky assets regardless
of their level of wealth
that's like a main sort of result from a
finance or like portfolio
models um in some sense that's sort of
irrelevant for you these are just
definitions in the sense of like if you
wanted to measure risk aversion
this is what economists have used mostly
okay
now if i give you these definitions how
would you actually
measure this if you wanted to know my
risk aversion how would you do that
and so let me give you actually a
utility function here
sorry it's let me let me give you
actually two utility functions here's
just examples of one example of a
constant absolute risk conversion
function
that you see here or like constant
relative risk aversion
cra this is what we mostly um use so
that's just a definition of a function
that has the property that it has
constant relative risk aversion you can
sort of verify that
um we're going to focus here on cra
functions which are sort of what
economists are mostly used
so now if i told you this is my utility
function my utility function looks like
this
now how would you estimate
my risk aversion
right so you could give me essentially
choices um
of outcomes uh that have essentially
some uncertainty or different risk
involved
and then i'll give you the choices
if i say i prefer one over the other can
you tell what my gamma is
what can you tell me or what can you say
yeah you can put some bounds on it right
so i'm going to show you this in a
second but essentially if i say i prefer
one option over the other
you're going to have like gamma on the
left-hand side gamma on the right-hand
side and give you some equations that's
essentially some inequality
and then if you solve that equation
you're going to get some bound on gamma
that's sort of essentially
tells you below or above or my risk
aversion must be below or above
a certain number what else could we do
yes exactly and that's what's called
like the
certainty or so uh the simplest way of
doing that is to say here's a lottery
between some gains or losses or two
gains with certain probabilities there's
some risk
involved and then we could ask you
what's the amount that makes you
indifferent between receiving that
amount for sure and
the gamble that i'm offering you now
that's called the certainty equivalent
essentially it's the the amount of money
if i have a certain gamble
what's the amount of money that if you
get it for sure makes you exactly
indifferent
between that amount of money for sure
and the gamble which is
uncertain right so if you then had the
certainty equivalent
now you could essentially just back out
what my gamma is by just solving the
solving for gamma um that's there let me
actually
show you that uh there's another thing
that we could do what else could we do
so we said okay if i give you gambles
choices between different gambles
i could ask you for certainty equivalent
now these are all kind of like
lab ways of doing this but if you looked
in the real world if you try to sort of
figure out in the real world how people
making these choices or choices in the
world
what kinds of choices could you observe
to figure out what people's gamma is yes
could you sell them insurance or an
option to mitigate their risk and figure
out how much they value that mitigation
exactly that's exactly right and that's
exactly what we're going to discuss and
what people have done
now it's a little bit tricky that in
usual cases if i just ask you like what
insurance have you chosen
it's a little tricky to figure out what
your gamma actually is because i don't
know what options you had
right so what i need is essentially a
choice set between
like suppose i'm selling you insurance
in particular what i'm going to show you
i think
next time is justin sidner's paper where
people can choose between these are
customers in a certain
home home insurance where people have
choices between different deductibles
right and now i can essentially say if i
choose a high deductible versus a lower
deductible essentially it's like
implicitly you're choosing the risk
exposure that you have for a price
so have like in sydner's case there's
like four different options that people
offered so he knows essentially
both the choice set like what are the
choices that people offered in this case
i guess they're often offered four
choices
and then the actual choice that they um
they made
again that's not going to give you an
exact gamma in terms of like pinning it
down exactly what it is because there's
like four different
inequalities that you get from these
choices but you can actually bound
as it turns out people's risk aversion
pretty well using those kinds of choices
exactly so that's what we have here is
like certain equivalence choices from
gambles
uh and insurance choices so let's start
with um certainty equivalent
so suppose your wealth um equals either
fifty thousand a hundred thousand
dollars each with probability
uh fifty percent suppose those those are
uh that's essentially like um there's
lots of risk in your life are those
fifty thousand hundred thousand
uh starting tomorrow are you going to
find out uh the chance of that is fifty
percent
each now of course that's hypothetical
but so but let's let's suppose that for
a second
your expected wealth then of course is
like 75 000
um now what guaranteed amount uh it's a
certain equivalent of the
wce do you find equally desirable right
if i could make all of your risks go
away
and just say i'm giving you a fixed
amount what amount would you choose
now when you
when you do that
essentially if i give you the if you
give me an amount w
uh a certainty equivalent uh that gives
me essentially an equation which is like
the utility from the certain equivalent
by definition
must be uh since you just told me that
uh must be the same as the weighted
average of the utility of fifty thousand
and the euro till two of hundred
thousand
with probability fifty percent each
right and once you do that now you get
essentially some non-linear equation
um uh uh that depends on gamma that you
can solve
perhaps not um uh not in close form but
you can essentially
figure out what the answer is in
mathematical or the like
okay now
as it turns out now
you can solve for this and the implied
values of gamma
like i've written down for here so if
you tell me if you tell me here um
uh 70 000 um gamma is one
you tell me 66 000 it's two fifty eight
thousand it's five fifty three thousand
that's 10
51 000 it's uh 30.
um who would say anything below 10.
yes no what would you say
so like value of gamma less than 10 yes
yes for sure that seems like very um uh
uh very reasonable if you think about
like in value of like
um uh 30 if you had a value of 30 you
probably would not leave the house
like ever and sometimes you would not
come to class or something because you
worried about like some
stuff falling on your head or the like
um because again
let me show you what the the lottery was
the lottery was between fifty thousand
and hundred thousand with um
with fifty percent chance if you tell me
you're different between that and like
fifty one 000 for sure
you were essentially valuing this like
small increment coming from 50
000 to 51 209 that's like thousands uh
209
dollars you value that a lot compared to
like the 50
50 chance of like actually getting
hundred thousand um
um dollars so we sort of think that
uh when looking at these large-scale
choices economists often assume i think
that
people's gamma is somewhere between zero
and two
okay so like somewhere maybe 70 000
maybe even lower than that
maybe 66 000 these are sort of
reasonable choices that we think people
are making or like you see people making
in their lives
um anything above that seems like it's
just not right because in some sense
that's not how people behave
in the real world people are comfortable
with at least some risk in their life
when you look at them so the broad
lesson is that choices involving large
scale risks suggest that
um gamma can't be um
too large okay
now second we can say okay so those sort
of are large scale choices now we're
going to look at sort of small scale
choices using
small gambles as deccent was just
alluding to so here's a choice involving
a small scale gamble
what if you had a 50 50 bet to win 11
and lose 10 who would take that bet
who would not take it okay
so so suppose you know
there's a question kind of like for all
of those questions now since
we need to know since your uh your
utility is not necessarily linear
we need to know what your wealth is
suppose it's 20 000 but you can choose
all sorts of other numbers
and you turn down a 50 50 bet to win
this is 110 and lose
100 you could do this for 11 and 10 as
well what can we learn now about your
your gamma and this is what i was saying
earlier
now is essentially if you turn down this
bet it must be that having 20 000 which
is like the status quo if you turn down
the bet
the utility of that is larger than fifty
percent of um
uh uh twenty thousand plus hundred ten
plus uh fifty
uh uh uh point five times the utility of
twenty thousand minus a hundred
again nice and can sort of then um uh
plug in the utility function and
essentially solve for
for gamma now i can show you if you
solve for gamma
um and and some of the um uh next
problems that is doing some of that is
like
essentially rejecting this bet is
implying that gamma
is like larger than 18. now
18 is actually not that large but surely
18 is larger than like two
and we just sort of agreed earlier on
that like gamma should be somewhere
below 10
presumably somewhere between around two
or maybe one
so what we get here now is like when you
look at large scale choices it looks
like people's gamma is like you know
somewhere between zero and two perhaps
like below five or something
but surely not above 10. when you look
at small-scale choices that seem pretty
reasonable and many of you seem to agree
that
like you know uh you might not want to
take certain bets
maybe your credit constrained to the
lake but but in any case um
it looks like people's gamma is really
large okay and so now the question is
like how do we sort of reconcile this
how do we put these things um together
now matthew raven has written a paper of
this and sort of says this is not just
sort of like an intuitive
argument uh this is a paper in
econometric from 2000
but in fact he sort of proves that um
when people reject small-scale gambles
that just sort of implies crazy stuff
for like large-scale choices
essentially stuff that just seems
completely implausible
and essentially he under minimal
assumptions proves that
uh this doesn't make um a lot of sense
now what i mean by this is uh what we
learned from this is that essentially
the marginal utility of money must
create a must uh extreme
uh decrease extremely rapidly if you
sort of take this model
uh uh seriously he does this under no
assumptions about the utility function
so it's not just some special case that
you sort of like doctored together with
some special assumptions of the utility
function
the only thing in fact that he's
assuming is that
the utility function is weakly concave
okay and so uh here's the example that
uh was also in your reading
suppose is johnny who is a risk-averse
expected utility maximizer
where the utility function where the
second derivative is
smaller equal than zero meaning that
essentially his utility function is
weakly
concave suppose that person turns down a
50 50
gamble of losing 10 or gaining 11 for
any level of wealth that assumption at
the end for any level of wealth is kind
of important but actually not
that important you can sort of relax
that
as well for our purposes we can sort of
mostly ignore it
now what's the biggest why such that we
know johnny will turn down a 50 50
lose 100 win uh y bet
so here are the answers um and um
what's the correct answer
g and why is that or can somebody
explain what's going on
yes um is
it because he will like reject this bet
for any level
so that kind of like implies that
he's not able to accept any level of
no no i think that's just because for
the iteration forward in the proof of
the people
of the thing like he needs to sort of
like make that argument
but in fact that's not essential there's
some
restrictions to that you can you can
prove the same thing maybe not as stark
in terms of a result but
this is just because he's iterating
forward he needs to sort of prove the
sequence of
utilities that derives but it's actually
not necessarily central
yes
yes so what's happening here is that
so let's sort of start very simply let's
start
with johnny's first choice that says
he rejects the bet which means
essentially on the right hand side is
utility of status quo of essentially
just utility of w
on the left-hand side is 50 chance of
winning 11.50
chance of losing 10 now you can sort of
um multiply this by two and rearrange
which gives you the second
line essentially that says that the
increase in utility going from w
to w11 plus 11 is smaller than the
increase in utility going from w minus
10
to a w okay that's just the left hand
side and the right hand side
i'm just rearranging terms so what that
means is that
again like on the left hand side is how
much does the utility increase
if i go from w to w plus 11 essentially
if i add 11
from coming from w that um utility that
he values by at most 10 11 so each
dollar that he gets
on the left hand side is valued at most
10 11 as much as the dollars between
w minus 10 and w right so if you have
like
10 dollars on the right 11 on the left
you prefer the right hand side of the
left-hand side which
means like each dollar must be valued
more on the right-hand side put
differently the dollars on the left-hand
side are values 10 11
of the dollars on the right-hand side
okay
so just to repeat again on the right
hand side we're adding 10 dollars
on the left-hand side we adding um 11
dollars
or subtracting we'll be adding left 11
on the left-hand side and we subtract
10 in the right-hand side now
since you prefer the thing or the thing
on the right hand side is larger
that must mean that each dollar on the
right hand side is worth more
it's 11 10 uh compared to the the
dollars on the left-hand side
or put differently each dollar in the
left-hand side is valued 10-11 of each
dollar on the right hand side
you can sort of think about this a bit
but trust me that is correct
now there's diminishing margin utility
essentially concavity sort of says that
the marginal dollar at w minus 10 is at
least as valuable as the marginal dollar
at w that's essentially just simple um
assumption of concavity essentially just
saying like there's diminishing marginal
utility
so the the lower the amount of wealth
that you have the larger or weakly
larger
the uh margin utility is so good the
margin utility at w minus 10
is uh at least as large as the margin
utility sw
and that marginal utility for a dollar
is at least as valuable as the marginal
utility at
w plus 11. now
sort of taken together that means that
johnny values a dollar at
w plus 11 by at most 10 11 as much as he
values the dollars
at w minus 10. what does that mean is
that if you go from w minus 10 to w plus
11
uh essentially the marginal dollar that
you get
is is worth 10 11 as much
for every 21 that he uh increases his
wealth
so i think
given the some of the confused phases i
see we might
do some of this in recitation but um
this is just essentially simple algebra
and using the assumptions um
uh the minimal assumptions that i made
now you can do the same thing as like if
the person were 21
is richer so essentially now i'm doing
the same thing just adding 21
dollars on each side i'm doing the exact
same thing
and i'm going to get essentially that
the exact same thing as essentially
saying that he values
each dollar that he gets at uh w plus 32
dollars but at most 10
10 11 so the power of two five six as
much as he values the dollars at
w minus ten so i'm essentially doing is
i'm iterating forward so i know the
utility function is concave
by sort of your first choice i know that
essentially you must the utility is
declining um
going on one side so now essentially
going taking this forward essentially
saying like
well for every 21 dollars you valued in
each dollar by 10 11's as much
so now i'm saying like well if you had
21 dollars plus like
21 is 42 dollars plus 20 is 63
your margin utility must be really
declining very very rapidly
so once you have like um a lot more
money than essentially
you just don't care at all about any
marginal dollar that you get
so you can do this by if the person was
like 42 dollars richer
um essentially okay about each dollar
five six as much
if it's 420 dollars you care about it
three twentieths as much
and if you were like eight hundred forty
dollars richer you care about it only
two hundredths as much
so essentially that's to say and this is
exactly as you were saying the marginal
utility plummets for substantial changes
in lifetime wealth
so you care less than two percent about
an additional dollar
when uh you are 900 richer
than you are right now that doesn't feel
right
but essentially it's like a simple
implication of what was just assumed
there's no magic here this is like very
simple algebra and very simple like just
using very simple minor assumptions
but essentially saying if this person
rejects this gamble as we just had
um it follows and there's sort of
complicated proofs in the paper
but it follows that essentially the
additional dollars for like if you give
the person 900
more um uh the person values each dollar
only two percent as much
as um uh when the person is 900 um
richer
and so then you look at sort of like
these um consequences and you can read
at this in the
raven and taylor paper or the original
um raven paper if you like
essentially you get these like absurd um
uh conclusions
if you look at the left hand side these
are sort of like if an expected utility
maximizer always turns down certain bets
on the left-hand side it follows that he
also turns down
the bets on the right-hand side and you
know we think you know
for example if i told you like
losing ten dollars or gaining eleven
dollars that seems like a reasonable
thing to reject perhaps that seems like
a thing that one might do
uh at least like you guys were saying
that you might do that
well if that's the case then you should
also
accept um or reject the gamble of like
losing a hundred dollars and gaining
like infinite amount of dollars
and that seems obviously absurd um um
and so so that can't be really um
um uh true now
what's going on here essentially is to
say is that
the utility function as it is an
expected utility has
trouble reconciling people's small scale
choices
and large-scale choices and it's similar
to what when we talked about like
exponential discounting
we only have like one parameter here
which is gamma
for both gains and losses and for all
sorts of scales
and that parameter is just not able to
fit people's choices in sensible ways
it seems to be people have like
small-scale risk aversion in some sense
and it seems to be people are like not
incredibly risk-averse for large
amounts of money and so now the expected
utility
model cannot match both of those things
that's essentially what the raven paper
um
does we'll talk about talk about this in
in
and some slower form and recitation uh
to sort of go over this
but in some sense uh the important part
here is to understand the intuition
and the intuition essentially is that if
there's curvature of a very small scale
or very small stakes it must be there's
lots of curvature
going forward over large scales and
that's just not plausible because
essentially then people would just not
value really really large amounts and we
know that people do value
money at least to some like
any uh questions on this overall
yeah um
i
[Music]
someone tried to do the
yeah um so what we're gonna gonna do is
so
notice that here he was not assuming
anything about the utility function the
only thing he was assuming
or raven was assuming here is
that the person is expected to tell the
maximizer and that the utility function
is weakly not even strictly um
concave now what that means is you can't
sort of like just change the functional
form because there's not even like this
is a general proof
for like any utility function that you
use
so what you have to do now is either
sort of say well
there's some other assumptions wrong
about expected utility in terms of
you know the weighting the probabilities
or stuff like that that essentially
uh uh you can explain the phenomenon
could be something about like
red diversion and so on they seem kind
of unlikely the most likely thing and
this is what we're going to talk about
next week is kahneman tversky's um sort
of lost aversion
framework where you say if you put
different weight on gains versus losses
then essentially you have like two
parameters you have one parameter about
like your risk conversion over gains
and you have a parameter that's uh that
steers kind of like how you feel about
losses compared to gains
so once you do that then you have
another degree of freedom and you can
explain a lot of
pavers um potentially but that's kind of
the equivalent of that exactly
but the difference here is that it's not
coming through like the utility function
the reason being that the problem is
actually not the utility function
because
as i said uh there's actually no
assumption here that that that can even
be changed because it's very general
for any function that you assume be it
any of the ones that i just
just showed you previously
okay
so then the last choice what might do
and we'll get started on this and
they're going to finish next time
is as you classmate was saying about
insurance choices so how do you do that
so this is a very nice paper by justin
sidner who's using sort of like real
world insurance choices and
um what's very nice about it that you
might not say well i might sort of say
well
college students and lab choices make
funky uh give you funky answers and
might not sort of
believe that this is really predictive
of anything in the real world
so we really want like real world
choices that people make in their lives
um um and sort of you might also worry
about demand effects and about sort of
like people behaving a little bit
funny in experiment so let's find like
real world choices that people have made
and
try to see maybe we can estimate gamma
using that
and so what justin citna has is like
data from a large home insurance
provider
um he has like a bunch of like standard
policies there's a random sample of
those so the 50 000
standard policies but he has importantly
he has both the options that people had
so like what is your choice set here's
four different choices for each person
and he has um then the choices that
people made
plus he has like claims that people made
after that he has like all the new
customers which matters a little bit
because you know you might say new
customers are confused maybe the old
ones are the ones that are right
now uh the key part here is like the
deductible that people were choosing
what is our deductible
yes
exactly so this is uh expenses paid out
of pocket
uh before the insurer um starts paying
any expenses
that would be like if you had some
damage to your house
for some small amount um you'd have to
pay that for yourself
if you have some large amount of the
damage you have to still pay the small
amount and then the insurer would pay
um the rest and that's usually used to
deter like large number of claims
because you know the insurance company
just doesn't want to pay for every 50
dollars of damage that you might have
because that's just really costly for
them to do for administrative costs
now what sydner has is choices over
menus of four deductibles
and again as i said they have or he has
like both
individuals choice set and their
preferred options if you only had the
preferred options it would be very hard
to figure out kind of like
what actually because you then can't
really say um
uh what's the counter factual you don't
know essentially what else
he could have chosen or she or he should
have chosen
so you kind of want to know different
options and then sort of the outcome and
then say okay
since you had these different options
available it must be that you preferred
one or the other it must be that you're
risk-averse
or not so here's kind of what these data
look like um the sample data are
deductibles okay this is again the
amount that you have to pay out of
pocket
until the insurer sort of kicks in and
pays for you there is the premium which
is like how much you have to pay every
year anyway regardless of what anything
what happens
um they're sort of uh relative to the
thousand dollar policy kind of what's
the premium
that's to say like how much more money
you have to pay for a certain
premium so for example uh choice one has
like a premium of five hundred four
dollars choice two has a
uh a premium of five hundred eighty
eight dollars so that's eighty four
dollars
uh higher um you pay essentially 84
in premium every year to reduce your
deductible from a thousand dollars to
500 okay so what you can do essentially
you can reduce your deductible at a
price
um the price relative to the thousand
dollar policy is in the third column
and you see the deductible on the
left-hand side so this person is like
policyholder
um if you're just comparing their
choices couldn't it be that they're just
a more risky person
and not necessarily risk first um
correct so that's exactly right so
there's sort of unobservable risks that
people might have
i'll get back to that but essentially um
what you see is that like
a lot of people make very similar
choices then on average people's risk is
relatively low
so what you're saying essentially i need
to know your claim rate i need to know
kind of like what's your probability of
actually having any damages
and it turns out claim rates are
extremely low in the sample
the order of magnitude of something like
below five percent or i think it's even
lower
um so it cannot be that everybody is
like a high-risk person
it can be potentially that everybody
thinks they're a high-risk person
but you know that's uh uh als that's
then there's a different mistake going
on
so what he's assuming essentially is
like on average people
are it must be that like there's some
high-risk people and some lowers people
but essentially he's sort of kind of
assuming this away and sort of saying
like look
on average claim rates are really low it
could be that there is some fraction of
like really
um uh high-risk people
but those can't be by definition since
only like something like five percent of
claims uh claim rates
it can't be that like there's everybody
is like a high-risk person
um so it must be that there's some
people
who behave as as if they're either
really risk-averse or as if they think
they're really high-risk people and this
is kind of where like the old and
new customers are helpful for because
there's some customers who have like you
know been at this company for like
10 15 years and sort of there you know
you kind of should
know that what kind of risk person you
you are perhaps
that's a great um question i'll actually
get back to that
okay so policy holder one is uh the home
was built in in 1966 he had an insured
value of 180
000 the menu available for this policy
and the same year was
uh the following and then he has also
the choice on the right-hand side you
see
the the policy that shows us so that
person chose for example
a deductible of uh 200
and for a price of like 157 dollars
relative to pi paying the 1 000
deductible
policyholder 2 similarly sort of chose
the first option notice that the price
has changed a little bit in part because
the company has sort of taken into
account some covariates and some risk
in some ways already so like the company
is kind of pricing specifically
depending on what your home value is and
maybe the area and so on and so forth
but since cydner has all that
information he can sort of just take
that into account
now what can we now say about risk
aversion how can we now sort of
estimate risk aversion using this these
choices
yes
[Music]
yes so what you need to know is
essentially a number of different things
you need to know the
deductibles the premium for adoption the
claim probability and the wealth levels
i'll talk about this in more detail but
essentially what you can do is
for each of these options you can write
down
an indirect utility of wealth function
you essentially can write down what's
the expected utility of that
option and then you can essentially just
put bounds essentially on like if you
preferred option one over option two
uh that tells me something about like
your gamma
and so what sidner then does is
essentially estimate gamma using
uh those different choices i'm going to
go over that in like a lot more detail
and slower next time